talks continue in the U.S between
Secretary of State Anthony blinken and
the foreign Ministers of Armenia and
Azerbaijan tensions have been high after
Baku installed a checkpoint at the start
of the Latin Corridor Road the only
route linking Armenia to the territory
of nagorno-karabakh well let's speak to
Bernard Smith he's in armenia's capital
Yerevan for us Bennett can you walk us
through the significance of these talks
they've been going for some time
Anastasia this is the longest period of
time foreign minister senior ministers
from Azerbaijan and Armenia have been
talking head to head in we understand
more than 20 years they were brought
together by Anthony blinken on a Sunday
he hold held to Chad bilateral talks
between the two and then the two
ministers and their counterparts and
their assistants have gone away and have
been talking since then they're
discussing an agreement on the
normalization of relations what brought
them together this latest bout of talks
was a decision by Azerbaijan to put in a
checkpoint on the main Latin Corridor
that leads the ethnic Armenians from
their Enclave into Armenia proper and
it's that checkpoint that is really the
shadow over these talks
Russian military convoys are the only
traffic now on this road that links the
ethnic Armenians in nagorno-karabakh
through Azerbaijan to Armenia
the Russians are peacekeepers and
supposed to keep the road open but
Azerbaijan set up a checkpoint last week
it's left ethnic Armenians stranded in
hotels in the nearest Border Town some
have been here since December when the
road was first blocked by azerbaijani
government-backed environmental
activists
we can't let the azerbaijanis check our
passports on principle there should be
no such thing I don't want to pass under
the poster welcome to Azerbaijan they
must realize that it is welcome to
Calabar
this is as far as we were allowed to go
on the Armenian side
two Wars sparked by the nagorno-karabakh
dispute between these former Soviet
republics has killed tens of thousands
of people
ethnic rivalry still smolders Azerbaijan
says it has a right to have a checkpoint
on its internationally recognized border
the problem is that the 2020 Russia
brokered peace deal between Azerbaijan
and Armenia says there's supposed to be
free movement of ethnic Armenians Into
The Enclave of nagorno-karabakh and now
there isn't
Azerbaijan is investing hundreds of
millions of dollars in the land it took
back from Armenia in the 2020 war and
has its site set on establishing
sovereignty over the part of karabakh it
doesn't yet control before the
occupation the half of the City's
population were azerbaijanis but
currently only Armenians living there
but I My Hope Is that very soon we will
be returning back to our constituency
with Russia apparently distracted by the
war in Ukraine the EU and U.S are now
trying to ease tensions
that if there's a checkpoint and they
they will have to go through those
checkpoints uh for sure Azerbaijan can
detain Armenians can create security
challenges and many other things so the
checkpoint the major reason of the
checkpoint is the ethnic cleansing
preparation process
the Border remains a dangerous place
seven soldiers were killed in fighting
in April but there's hopes that the
talks taking place in Washington DC May
produce some sort of a deal now in their
fourth day it's the longest period of
time ministers from both countries have
met in more than 20 years
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera on the Armenia
Azerbaijan border
Russia says it welcomes any attempt to
bring peace between the two sides but it
wants to be involved in any agreement
should be on the basis of that 2020
peace deal that the Kremlin brokered but
Armenia has been very frustrated with
Russia's involvement in this it says
that Russia should have stopped them
building the checkpoints of Azerbaijan
building the checkpoint and it didn't
and it didn't provide Azerbaijan Armenia
with the support excuse me it expected
to have when that checkpoint was built
that's why uh Armenia sort of reached
out asked the US and the uh the EU and
the US to get involved in future peace
negotiations
Bernard Smith there with the latest for
us keeping an eye on those talks from
Yerevan thank you very much Ben